I'm really glad about that because it's
obvious that these companies are looking
at that like y we can't do this man you
know you know somebody looked at Jim
Ryan you know road map was like nah bro
it's saying maybe Jim Ryan did it was
like n we can't do
this it's just like I'm glad about that
because again it's a return to a
normalization and seeing the industry
for what it is and where it is and
making sound decisions about the type of
games you put out there what the market
wants what the market will accept cuz
again I don't think the market will
accept like hey we can't give you these
you know these beautiful 4K games games
are going to go back to
1080P and they gonna be five hours
longer just we may not get that 100 hour
crazy you Styles I don't I don't see
those type of games